là je constate un sapin de noël
normalement jusqu'à pâques qu est-ce que
c'est une tradition chez toi en italie
ou non parce que j'aime bien j'aime bien
noël et après je relève a pas que parce
que bas parce que c'est l'été après
j'ai tout à part prendre la poussière
voilà une image que l'on pourrait voir
de plus en plus c'est en tout cas ce que
souhaite la ministre de la santé le
retour du masque dans les transports je
n'irai pas jusqu'à l'obligation mais en
tout cas je demande aux français de
remettre le masque oui effectivement
dans les transports
[Musique]
c'était bidon ya rien de plus contagieux
qu'un transport en commun en plus les
gens font pas attention il touche tous
je suis pour le porter je le porterai je
le mets parce que je pense qu'il est là
le cosy délire partie un petit peu
autour de moi j'ai plein de gens qu'on
le croit vite du coup je le mets quand
même au cas où
je trouve que c'est hyper exagéré belani
je vous trouve un petit peu dur quand
même pour pour la majorité un les filles
la semaine dernière à paris la fête de
la musique pas son plein aucune
restriction
aucun masque
mais après des semaines d'accalmie le
coc vide va-t-il gâcher les vacances
d'été il est aussi de notre devoir à
tous de donner l'exemple 1 naturellement
pensions avoir regagné un espace de
liberté absolue
les embrassades les serrements de mains
mais je vous êtes positive donc vu que
vous êtes vacciné vous avez les 3 2
c'est un isolement de sept jours le non
port du masque et cetera
je n'aime pas ce dont
j'ai le droit de le dire je n'aime pas
de donner l'exemple je n'aime pas les
embrassades je n'aime pas qu'on parle
comme ça en fait mais bon ça ne regarde
que moi faut pas me regarder un bien non
c est christian estrosi c'est vraiment
une journée laisse tomber je passe
j'attends la suite je content de vivre
ces joutes le bus je roule sur rooney
kaka mes enfants sont excités cas est un
point positif c'est quoi il fait beau et
ça réchauffe le coeur nous en réchauffe
le fun
soixante deux rescapés au départ de la
15e étape toulon dans ton la chaleur et
tropicales on en boit et on fait comme
les estivants montrant un bain de mer je
trouve qu'il fait chaud
[Musique]
une vague de chaleur historique étouffe
le centre du japon les températures y
dépasse les 40 degrés et la saison des
pluies est déjà terminée le gouvernement
vient d'appeler les habitants de tokyo
et des régions voisines à réduire leur
consommation électrique menacé de
pénurie même situation dans le sud de la
chine où les habitants se ruent dans les
piscines et les parcs aquatiques
en témoignent ces images de baignade
géante pris ce week-end à diouf
pour combattre la chaleur tous les
moyens
et à chacun sa méthode
[Musique]
ya quand même un truc qui va pas oui
bien sûr rios littérature bd attend un
pays vous avez un tel niveau d'extrême
droite et d'extrême gauche c'est un pays
où en tout cas on a la perception qu'on
va mal ça ses yeux hariti extraits d'
arrêter aussi avec l'extrême gauche
arrêtez pascal juste qu'on fait c'est ça
que je veux dire un truc tout de suite
pour ne pas rester de double expliqué
que les gens du rassemblement national
sont d'extraire des gens des défis sont
d'extrême gauche parce que je pense que
vous allez le mauvais le move et
logiciels
[Musique]